all right hutch welcome back thank you
mark great to have you back again glad
to be here you gave one of my favorite
talks on my channel
i several months ago
i got a lot out of it that i didn't know
i would for sure that's for sure
did you read the comments and
my son did actually my son
we got back i got back to hawaii like a
week after we did it and i think that's
when it posted like probably the night
after i got back
and um i was i couldn't do it i couldn't
like read the comments and stuff i was
too like um
self-conscious about it a lot of people
have it yeah it was a trip it's a trip
the the people that watch the show or
watch this channel are like
hands down the nicest people in the
world or at least the people that
comment are you know yeah my viewers are
probably the most evolved compassionate
group empathy
yeah on social media they try to place
themselves in your shoes which is really
cool i never had such a cool response
and then i had family hit me up i had
like friends hit me up people getting
into contact with me people i was in the
military with especially and um
it's been like a really cool ride ever
since then you know it's been a cool
thing
um such a beautiful talk yeah thank you
that your your talk was the exact
prototype of what i try to do on my
channel so that's like the coolest thing
that's cool that you say that dude
because um
i didn't know anything about the soft
white underbelly in any way shape or
form before other than i saw a interview
of you
uh somebody asking you what the channel
is about and stuff so
i literally when my friend contacted me
our mutual friend contacted me and said
hey my buddy might want to interview i
literally thought like this is a guy
that owns a rehab
and he's doing like these videos to show
people
and stuff like that and then um
when it posted
is when i saw what the channel was and
was like holy [ __ ] like this is like
this is something else you know
and then watching the video myself
i was so proud i was like so proud of
myself that i was able to
put in the words and
um
[Music]
and just talk just talk with you about
stuff that you know it seems to have
gotten a good response i did notice i
think people
were a little confused as to like
i am a sensitive person
i'm okay with that
i'm an emotional person i feel my
emotions they
um are big you know like like we talked
about
but
it does not mean
that i wasn't made to do what i did
you know the thing that that
tripped me out was that
like i i didn't realize how it came
across that
maybe i regret
the my military experience or something
like that
and that wasn't that's not the case i
don't
there's things that i've done that i
regret
there's things that
i feel i could have done better or or
not you know
but i was good at soldering
really good at it
and i have an honorable discharge and
um
i have a tattoo on my face but i'm not a
crackhead dude you know um and that
doesn't really
define
me you
okay
you know it doesn't really
my tattoos are another part of like a
map on me as to you can like you can hit
checkpoints on my tattoos on my body and
say okay that's probably where he was in
his life at that time they tell a story
but what they don't do is tell you what
kind of person i am
you know that's the that's one thing
that i noticed is like i think we judge
each other off the cover so fast
we might not even hear each other out
but i i noticed in the comments people
like i was just gonna skip him another
tattooed face crackhead and then they
didn't and
then they said something super nice and
i'm just like
i'm really glad that
this person
said that
you know the things that people said my
son was crying
when he was like dad these people they
like you they think you're nice you know
they're they're they know you like i do
now you know that's great to hear
yeah okay
before you before we finish this again
we'll bring your son out here put him on
camera oh that'd be so cool i brought
him with yeah so um yeah that'd be so
cool he'd be stoked he's gonna get all
red-faced i guarantee it
um
yeah we were
we were living in hawaii in that places
um
i don't think a lot of people in the
united states know that
there's third world countries
inside our country
you know
and it was a hard place for us to live
it was a hard place for us to live we
just moved back that's right
three and a half four years almost and
um oh the big island on the back side in
puna which is like
i don't know it's got like a low murder
rate by the highest missing persons in
the country that should tell you
something you know and then boys out
there ain't playing they're not they're
not playing around they're not you know
um
if you want to experience
what i
if you want to experience racism
open an open
culture of racism
go to hawaii go to go to a small part of
hawaii where you're not there's no
tourism
and see
if it feels good if you're a racist
white person
go to hawaii
and see how it feels
you'll catch some of the
southern style racism
in minutes yeah i have a story about it
myself but it's it's the it's
it would be the equivalent of being a
black person in mississippi mississippi
in the 70s is how i
perceive it like i saw it like there's
people that are really trying to be like
no we're not racist it's just a racist
term you know there's a there's a
there's like a the n word for white
people out there it's called howie right
and there's three definitions and i'm
not i can't i don't i'll paraphrase one
means foreigner
one means without breath so in the
hawaiian culture they would touch
foreheads and breathe ha
and that is how they would pass on each
other's mono or energy and like you know
that's how the it was their soul
so without breath means you have no soul
so because my skin was white i was
automatically judged as a person without
a soul
where are we but i already i knew this
going into it
and i
have been a minority most of my life you
know have been in the minority
population wherever i was and um
but if you want to learn
you want to learn about racism
and you're white and you don't know how
it feels
go experience it you know maybe you'll
be less ignorant in the end i know i am
you had incidents there
man
um
[Music]
fighting for my life i had to fight for
my life twice there
straight
surviving um
i thought it would be a good place to
raise my son you know and buy a piece of
property cheap
for him to inherit that happened i did
that
but we had to split and we had to get
out you know it's
rumors can get you killed
um 200 bucks can get you killed
you know this is a place that it's like
it's like um
it's poverty man it's poverty in the
united states and wherever you
experience high levels of poverty you're
going to experience high levels of
violence
and people that are willing to inflict
violence on each other without a
moment's notice
and it was like a war zone
i literally
i literally
wonder if the va has like a hawaii
survivor branch that i can visit and
and and go to eventually
that sounds pretty soft to me but
yeah that was um that was an experience
and i'm glad we're back i'm
happy to be home in california
happy back in la
my dad just retired um
[Music]
my dad saw the video
now that was a conversation my
grandmother recently passed away
so
we came out here initially for the
funeral but stayed
um
and um
at the funeral
i asked my dad if you saw it because i
had family members that kind of were
dancing around it
they wanted to say hey i saw it but they
didn't know how to
deal with
the content
you know i had some family members that
were like yo that was really powerful
dude and that was super cool
because
they got to know me better
and
those that i shared in front of everyone
something that i hadn't shared with
anyone before
you know maybe three people that weren't
there knew about it
and now it's like my darkest my deepest
darkest secret i
just put it out there and it did some
really good things for me healing wise
you know
i think if
i think we hide a lot of our
i think it's necessary too
a lot of our traumas
we we bury them deep you know and i
don't think it's just a traditional way
of doing things as an american man to
just swallow it eat it hide it
let it boil over when you get drunk and
your wife's being mouthy
no i think that
these traumas have to like they have to
either come out naturally or they have
to be drawn out of you in order to
process them and move on or they come
out in ways you don't want them to or
they'll and they'll continue to rear
their heads
over and over and over until
you work it out it's yeah it's
and
that i'm so so i'm i'm super stoked that
we had that talk dude
i'm super stoked that we had that talk
like um
i didn't i did not realize how impactful
it was gonna be
um
but like my my girlfriend
she watched it and was like
i'm so glad you did that because i know
you better
you know
um
yeah yeah and i've been seven years
we've been on and off together you know
and she knows me better than anybody
else and i love that girl
um nicole she's the most amazing thing
she's been dealing with my problems
for seven years you know
i can't imagine
[Music]
the amount of of patience it must have
taken her
to
sit there
and
wake up next to me same [ __ ] that my son
is dealt with you know
baby you're okay
i've been woken up and heard that phrase
more times than i'd like to admit
because i don't know what i was just
putting that person through
you know and it's not my fault per se
you know as much as
but it's a reality it's there
for her to volunteer
and to stick it out
and just say there's a better there's
something better on the other side of
this you know this person's in pain
they're the the pain is coming out
in different directions and they're not
aware of it
and
to
to to any family member right to any
military person that's that
has um a similar diagnosis or has the
same types of issues that i do where
feelings come up
from
memories
feelings arise and they can't be
just breathed out real quick you can't
just they don't go away the feeling
stays with you
after
um
you know the thought has come and gone
so anybody that that has the patience to
like
sit with somebody
and
stick that out
i
that's who what my hat's off to the
people that deal with us you know
and
the community could also include people
with
like borderline personalities anybody
but bipolar all these things anybody
that if you don't understand you just go
this this chick's crazy and you kick her
out and you don't give him a chance you
don't give me a chance i mean look okay
so
i'm looking at the video right i'm
watching the video and i'm saying like
wow dude look at your face you know
you don't i don't hear myself looking
like that
does that make sense
don't hear yourself
like if you closed your eyes you would
never imagine the person talking
to look like me
and i'm saying that because of this
because of the tattoos
because
who does this
you know
there's a reason and when i got this
tattoo it was it was specifically i had
a specific reason in mind it wasn't a it
was a um it was an impulsive decision
but at the same time the decision came
with forethought it came with
will this help me
at some point and when i was living in
hawaii yes
it was another thing like my veteran
mask
it may it would it would give people
pause
and say
brah you know i got to make a i got to
make a couple assumptions here
this person doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know about what i think you know
that's usually what a face tattoo says
it says i don't care what you think
about me you know and everybody i know
who has a face tattoo cares about what
you think about them you know that's the
whole point you know so
it was a thing that i used as like a
defense mechanism it says airborne it
says airborne that was what everybody
there called me that was the nickname
that i got out there was airborne
because
one thing they do respect
in hawaii is the veteran culture the
warrior culture you know they're a
warrior culture
and they respect somebody that's gone to
war and come back and return
so
the more easy it was for you to know me
as that person the faster
you
the faster i was
taken seriously
the faster people were
i mean people were less inclined to
attempt
um blatant violence out of and to to
like a show of violence to
to get me to do what they want
right
i think people
are they flash is what like is that a
term for it when people flash at you
they're trying to
see right then and there
if you're going to stand your feet stand
on your feet or back down you know and
most of the time
people that i know that do that
are hoping you back down
you know so i think this tattoo is one
of those things that i got is like i
hope you back down
because i'm actually
i was good at soldiering
i excelled at violence
i took it serious
and none of that [ __ ] just goes away
you know you don't just wake up one
morning and forget how to hit somebody
in the face you know it can
almost be like a second nature
um
does that make me proud of that [ __ ] no
but i know that about myself
i know that i can stand my stay on my
ground i know that i can defend myself i
know i can keep my kids safe my
girlfriend's safe um and those kinds of
experiences
and i don't run from them like they
don't make me nervous i mean the way
that i think that people that haven't
really experienced a lot of violence
would and by it's like experience is the
only teacher in that situation really um
i
i'm i'm
i might have come off
like i'm
i just people i i guess i just hope
that people that said the things that
they said meant it
you know i'm sure they did
you know that's like um because i read
it and i took it all to heart
and
you know and even the people that say
you're full [ __ ] i'm all right dude then
you get that on every video you're gonna
get that no matter what you know and
oh
i think a lot of people saw
me
and saw it as like is this person an
example of a veteran and it's like
who is to say what a veteran is
supposed to be like after
they get back right you have you take
all these boys and girls
you put them in a you know you put them
through a system
you train them to do a certain thing
they do it they're still the same
individuals they're still individuals
but now they have this all this common
concept right this this mentality of
warrior i guess is what we'll call it
when they get back
is there like a dress code
that i missed out on is it should i be
wearing the baggy pants the baggy cargo
pants
and a tucked in polo shirt and an
american flag with like a like a
velcro american flag on the hat and like
a grow beard should i do that is that
like a veteran in america
because i think those guys are the ones
that are you know
the picture people have in their mind
and i was amazed to even read that
ignorance
in our culture and see how
much people were like kind of
disappointed that i have regrets
you know it's like you're a soldier in
the united states military you're you
should be strong stay strong and
keep it strong you know and i get that
it's necessary when you're at war but
when i come back let me [ __ ] grieve
my way
you know let me um
let me have my regrets it's okay for me
to regret some of the things i did
that's more than okay if i didn't i
don't think i'd be a good person
you know i you can
you can interview a veteran and hear
them sit there brag
about the things they've done and see
how good that comes out
or talk to somebody that says you know
all that [ __ ] wasn't really what i
knew was gonna happen
and i
still have [ __ ] nightmares about it
i believe that you'll get more out of
the person who's approaching it from an
open mind
and saying hey
post you know post the the
war
i've been able to step back and remove
myself
from it and remove the way i look at
myself and say what the [ __ ] happened
why am i being affected
um i don't think i'm a i don't think
that somebody is less than weaker [ __ ]
[ __ ] any of those words that
go hand in hand with somebody that says
like
man i cry about some of the [ __ ] i did
i applaud that person you know i think
that's the stronger of the individuals
than the one that swallows it and says
i'm the [ __ ] you know i went over there
and did all sorts of craziness and i'm
stoked
that doesn't come off as healing to me
you know what can you get from that well
you're you're a human before you're a
veteran bingo
what can you get from that what what do
we get from that
um
what do we get from the hard ass how
what have we learned in life you know
let's say over the last 20 years in
psychology what have we learned about
the hard ass
what addition does that person give to
culture society not much nothing there's
not much of an addition there um
so i have said to myself in like in an
aware state
how can you add
because i'm done subtracting
i'm done taking away
and i've been done since 2008
and i knew that
and i talked about um last time about
how my brother asked me to stop drinking
that was a big deal for me you know
alcohol is a big part of the military
it's like they [ __ ] put it on you
like they literally encourage you to get
wasted they have the they have military
balls they have picnics beer is provided
it's the only thing that's free
that's interesting
it's a legal corrosive substance
it is one of the most addictive
substances it is the most destructive we
have found so far in society and that
it has the worst effect
on on us as a society and not only is it
legal but it is
like i still hear guys tell me about
what they drank saturday night bro you
think i'd give a [ __ ] how many
jagermeister shots you can do
you know
what does that do for my kid
you know what does that do for your mom
what does that do for
the world around you you know
and i guess
i guess
i've decided i decided a while ago that
i was going to become one of those
people that wants to just add [ __ ]
you know
i want to be in addition to every
everywhere i go i don't want to feel
like somebody
is going to leave with the feeling of
man i don't want to [ __ ] see that guy
again
and i don't have an ego in that way to
where
um
my image of me is more important than
your
feelings you leave once we've
experienced each other the feelings you
have about me when we leave each other
matter to me they matter
it makes a [ __ ] difference
um
if i'm an [ __ ] or not
you know
i think so
i think it makes a difference if
i affect people negatively even if i'm
confident about it it does not
make it right
and
i'm kind of just going off of the things
that i
know what what i loved about your talk
yeah
for me personally it was so relatable
like i could you know if i had been born
10 years earlier or something maybe i
would have been drafted right forced to
go into the military without you know
which would i would never do but let's
say i got drafted you got to go serve
your country different yeah
listening to your talk made it like but
this
this is what it would have been like if
i had gone
right
you know the things you experienced how
you dealt with them how you're dealing
with them
seemed like that's how i would deal with
it
that's good to know that i'm not you
know what i mean because i feel i i
guess i have i still have this like
overwhelming feeling that i
put myself out there as somebody that's
like
like oh the military beat me up it's
like i'm not a victim i'm not a victim
of anything i did i i don't believe so
yeah i want to make that clear it's like
yo i don't feel like i'm a victim of the
military i don't feel like the united
states did that to me i feel like
i'm just a person with regrets man you
know who went through war yeah and i
have regrets or does this people it
[ __ ] people up dude and if people go
through that and come back and don't
think they're [ __ ] up
somebody's going to [ __ ] feel it
somebody else will feel it down the line
you know and that's why like what's cool
about what we were able to talk about is
that like it seems like
i didn't even know i was coming as an
advocate for veterans i had no idea but
i am
i am i think it's a very serious thing
you know i think winston churchill was
one of the people that said you can
judge a society based off of how they
treat their veterans
you know some smart guy said that
sometimes yeah
and that's a good indicator of
the way we treat our people
go off of the people that
selflessly served
that went over there and thought they
were doing the right thing and i still
in my heart believe i joined for the
right reasons it wasn't just to get out
of trouble it wasn't just like you know
there were challenges
that you face in the military there's
things put in front of you test put in
front of you
and it's a pass it's either a go no go
and then there's also courses you can
take classes and things you can take to
where there's like you're putting to a
percentile
of how well you do commandant's list
right every school i went to not every
school
but everyone i went to after i'd already
gotten to the 82nd everyone division
i graduated in the commandant's list
because i [ __ ] took it serious
it's not
it's everything
they're teaching you is teachable you
know it's learnable um
but i think you know there's people that
gave up on themselves quickly and people
that were just right lazy they were just
like [ __ ] that that's extra work i'm
cool on that but i took every single
class every course every school as a can
i do this
you know i was insecure
as a young man
um
growing up in la
the way that i did
i was super insecure and sensitive [ __ ]
dude sensitive is like one of those
things you know where people are like
man you're sensitive and you're like
[ __ ] you you're [ __ ] sensitive i was
one of those i was um i like ugly
duckling syndrome i was like
i never believed that i was a you know
uh um good enough for anything anybody
at all i just didn't have that belief
and it's not my dad's fault
it's not even my mom's fault you know
ran off with uncle um
it's probably just your dna it's just
the way that i perceived [ __ ] you know
um
and the way that we see things like okay
like there you and i are both sitting in
the same room right now
you're
seeing we can put something in the in
the center of the room
between us and we're looking at the same
exact object
same exact one
but we're seeing literally two different
pictures
right
who's to say your experience is any less
effective
than mine or
you know we could have that's that's
what i was mean by like these things
happen to us individually
like
we're perceiving the same exact
situation the same exact thing but from
two different angles
whose is the right angle
no one's to say no one's to say so for
people that have experienced abuse for
people that have experienced um
heartache a hardship
the things that we experience
who's to say that the way that they
perceived it was wrong
oh you saw that you didn't see that
right
it's like
what do you [ __ ] mean right you know
um
i guess it's just like my intrigue in
human psychology is just like
the amount of therapies i've done and
stuff have taught me some [ __ ]
um
one is
awareness is the key
knowing you're experiencing something
when it's happening is bigger than
knowing why
in the moment no just knowing
that oh [ __ ]
i think i'm you know you know let me
take me out of the moment real quick and
[ __ ] say holy [ __ ] i'm you know i'm
having a um
i'm having an effect on the world around
me
um
that all bases off of that same
perception
the same the thing in the room and from
what angle
so
my childhood
could have been like my brother my i
have a brother named kenny he's the [ __ ]
um
he's the one that asked me to stop
drinking we have the same exact
childhood
100 same exact one
he has anxieties in places that i don't
and i had anxieties in places he didn't
we work really well together and we
always will i like my brother's my best
friend and um
he
sometimes i'll tell him a story and
he'll be looking at he'll give me a
strange look and i'm like what and he's
like i don't remember it happening that
way and in my head that's the [ __ ]
way it happened man
and he's like no dude i think you missed
this part
you know and how often do you think that
happens to people
we might have missed the part i think it
happens all the time i think it happens
every day all day people interview you
you'll hear them tell a story
and you know you're always like you know
that the parents would tell the story
differently right and you know that the
spouse or the victim or the whatever
would tell that story differently but
that's it's that person's reality yeah
that's the way they saw it and the the
picture can be painted you know pretty
gnarly right yeah you know
yeah yeah totally well what's really
what i've learned from from doing this
for years now
is that
you know the comment the viewers the
commenters are very compassionate and
very kind of empathetic and very evolved
which is great i'm proud of that
but i don't think we can ever really
truly understand what it's like to grow
up in extreme poverty
in the hood
with a dad that was in prison a mom that
was on drugs a sister that was a hoe and
she sat there and walked and you're
surrounded by gang members and pimps and
hustlers and con artists and you're
supposed to go out there and just go get
a job and thrive and thrive go kick ass
and you'll see these simplistic
suggestions in the comments like oh just
quit that yep
you get a job at the grocery store
and it's like do something simple
yeah it's like
unless you can live in her shoes
you're never going to get it the
complexity
of ptsd
that's why i do these videos right you
and you you like
man you're my hero mark you're my hero
um
the complexity of ptsd
is such to where if you don't suffer
from it right and i think everybody
suffers from it in some form or another
even if the [ __ ] santa didn't bring
you what you want you're still bummed
out dude you're 80 years old chill you
know um
anything that sticks with us
post traumatic stress after the fact
stays with you
is all based on
the way we felt while we perceived it
in my that's just the way that i have
come to grips with [ __ ]
if you felt like it was your fault
you're going to live in this feeling of
i did that or i wasn't enough to make it
work or anything like that
um
if you
felt like it was being done to you
there's the why that people grow up with
we have all these y's right why did that
happen
and truth be told
i've boiled all the y's down to one
thing
doesn't matter
the y
only
the y is an individual thing
the y is for me
right
if i can put a y on it maybe then i can
understand it better
and once i started letting go of the why
and started accepting exactly what
happened as it happened
and tried to pull my feelings out of it
in the moment i couldn't process [ __ ]
i'd stay cloudy and stay hurt i would go
to therapy and we would talk and i'd be
there for an hour and i'd feel i'd leave
feeling better i'd be crying on the way
home
you know and
that has to do with the fact that i
still would get i would get caught up on
the the why me
you know
and
like you're saying that that person that
one that girl that grew up in that life
right the game no no examples just gang
members everywhere like all that
gangster [ __ ] no role models nothing
probably got
sexually abused there's so many more of
those people than not
in my opinion
right like the mass
the majority of the populist united
states lives in the urban areas and it's
in like the metropolitan areas
that's where you're going to see the
poverty that's where you're going to see
people rubbing rubbing up against each
other a lot
there's
when you think about it it's like if you
don't get saddened by it
if you're not saddened by the fact that
i think there's more people hurt than
not
then what's you know then
you have an askew version of the way the
world works
and that's that's something that i saw
in the comments too there are some
people that have some really trippy
views on things you know i said i don't
know do you read the comments sometimes
it's it's kind of fun because you can be
on there you're reading and somebody's
like man thank you you did this or hey i
was at the same time bro i know this
dude knows you're talking all that kind
of [ __ ] and then you're like the person
is like donald trump
we're going to war with russia it's
buying his fault i was like
i don't know how to thumbs up this [ __ ]
dude you know like there's that then
people are so stuck in those moments in
this like moment in this like feeling of
whatever hate i want to hang on to or
whatever cause i feel like i'm behind
like they can't literally step out for a
second and see what was right in front
of them hate judgment separation is it's
all an addiction
it's gnarly people are addicted to it
it's like it's hot it's as bad as heroin
it is people won't let go of it and what
i'm hoping to do with this is just like
break some of that
just a little understanding
we'll break that all down it really will
it really will and that's why i'm like
stoked at you like let me come back and
talk because like
i will do more that'd be cool dude i
like doing this i like um
well i just like i like um i'm verbose
i'm loquacious i know you have really
great thoughts and you're a sensitive
person which i love which is you know
you're not a tough badass you're you're
you've been a tough badass when you had
to be but right you're generally like i
am a much more sensitive person yeah you
feel you feel everything
i was born that way yeah i truly i
believe that i believe i was born i was
like one of those kids that my aunt told
me this
so when i first
when i first got sober in 2011
okay
before i turn myself in to the feds
my aunt said we knew
you were gonna have
problems
when you were six and seven years old
and you were asking questions that we
could not answer
you're asking questions about why do
people do that to each other
why is this happening why why a lot of
the wise at a young age she was like we
knew you're so your bit your heart was
going to feel some [ __ ] you know
and when you take a big heart
and put it in a small room
anybody walking by you're going to feel
it you know and
i pride myself man
in
saying i have a big heart
i pride myself in the fact that i would
rather love than hate
i pride myself on the fact that i will
teach my son
my son does not have an angry bone in
his body i don't know what happened
i have i have i tried to shelter him as
much as possible but i have not hid [ __ ]
from him i have not hidden anything
about the world from him
you know
um
if you're doing a great job of
breaking the uh the cycle cycle like my
father i don't blame him
for any of the ways he used to raise us
you know my dad is very short
with his words he does not say much
he um
he raised 11 kids
two which were not his my they were my
oldest sisters
um they're 18 now they just turned 18.
and he's 75 and literally just retired
this year because for the first time in
48 years he's not raising a child in his
home
that's my hero
you know somebody that can put it all
down
everything they want know or love in
life to say i need to take care of this
person first
if we're not [ __ ] giving them the
medals you know
we're really looking in the wrong
direction
um
i don't consider myself
special because i raised my kid i
consider myself somebody that's doing
what they're supposed to do you know and
if that's the only thing i'm doing right
dude [ __ ] it i'll take that hit all
right so who is this
that's chance patrick hutchinson this is
my son
the baby i talk about
hey chance hi
so were we lying are you happy to be my
son you know and i'm happy to be your
dad are you sure bro yes promise yes
doing some right i'm doing something
right hold it chance
um nine nine
tell me about your dad
um he is 38. no tell me about your dad
oh um he's awesome
yes he's very tall six four
oh yeah
what else um
when you think about your dad what do
you think of
you best at math
the best at math
what about if somebody would say
um
what what's your favorite part about
your dad being your dad
that you're my dad
like
um
do i let you be you yes
like i want you to be who you are
not who i want you to be
why
do you know what
you want to be a good dad
that is a good dad you know
but it's because
who you are isn't up to me
you know
i can keep you safe
right
but i can't predict or determine how
you're going to treat other people
so how do i help you treat other people
well um
raise me to be that way
the nice way to be nice
how's that how do i raise you to be nice
you take care of me you love me
bingo
do i do things that i don't want you to
do
yes sometimes yes he's honest
but
do i explain to you
the difference between right and wrong
and what i'm doing even even when i'm
doing something that's not okay do i
tell you that i'm not supposed to be
doing this yes
honestly
i'm honest with you
am i honest with you yes i think that's
important though
you think it's one of the important
things do i hide stuff or anything
no not really right no
because if i'm doing it
then
i shouldn't have to hide it
i think
were you twisting your arms down yeah i
don't know i'm just playing with
tweezers
that's what we tend to do yeah
yeah
you're in good shape chance you're doing
good so far i've never seen him angry
ever
i've never seen him angry lash out he's
never talked back to me
never i
once wanted to cry before i get angry
yeah
he's sensitive too
that's great that's really cool it's a
great quality man he's like he's like
the uh the watchers of your channel he's
just empath you know like totally
empathetic
did you watch them did you watch the
video yes did you read the comments yes
and were they pretty good
did you like the things people are
saying
yeah it's pretty cool huh just the
haters suck haters
yes they do that's right we love our
haters bro
they're obsessed with us
let them hate
yeah somebody explained to me all the
haters they're haters then why do they
watch it they watch they watch
religiously yeah those are the ones that
are yeah and they're like picking apart
they're like look at his hair there's no
way he's really that person he has brown
hair there's no way he's that person
it's like i don't know where these
people where their opinions come from
you know some of them are pretty far out
pretty far out
nice though but you're real
yes you're really my son yes you're
really here yes you're nine years old
yes have you ever had to wake me up
because i was having a nightmare yes
yes and then i cuddle with you and go to
bed
and then
the night's all done
have i always been honest with you about
the way that the war has affected me yes
what have i told you
um it was hard after that
and
losing your friends
yeah that was really hard too yeah
and
that's really changed
yeah
but if i get mad at you do you think i'm
mad at you or mad at something you've
done
you might have something i've done
why
because getting mad at you does
does that help huh
that's the big one that's i think where
we broke the cycle
is that because you're just telling me
not to do it yeah i don't get i never
want my son to feel like i'm mad at him
or like he's the problem
you know like my father he didn't know
in the moment it was happening but i
always thought he hated me i thought he
hated me i really did you know and i
never ever want my son to think i have
anything but love for him you know
there's only one love that matters and
it's unconditional love it's the one
that you get yeah it's the one you give
right it's the only one that counts
hmm are we are we learning yes we are
thank you
all right you guys thank you very much
thank you
you